uh all right so do we have sound
yeah
i'm not sure
all right uh so hello everybody uh my
name is kevin i'm a software engineer at
datadog
and i'm here with you today to talk
about uh debugging
more specifically uh debugging one layer
deeper
so yeah we have the cuts that's perfect
so uh what do i mean by one layer deeper
well in the past i've already talked
about uh how to debug programs in your
dotnet application
but this time i will i would like to
focus on a more insidious kind of
problem where
the issue comes from the interaction
with native code
and i think most of developers won't
have to face this kind of problem uh
during that job at least i'm hoping
hoping so but by showing you how to
tackle this kind of issue that looks
overwhelmingly complex at first and how
to break it down into simple problem and
solve them individually
i'm hoping that you will learn a few
tricks that you can use for your own
investigations
um i will start with a few words of
warning uh first i'm going to focus on
the process rather than the tooling so i
will be showing some windy bg command
and i will give only the minimal amount
of explanation about them
uh if you are
interested in knowing more test
ferrandes has a talk later today about
advanced debugging and i'm sure that she
would cover this kind of stuff into more
details
also there will be some assembly code so
don't worry i will explain it but if you
have a phobia that's a good moment to
leave the room
and
that's a detail but the description of
the talk mentioned aadb that's because
it's the description for an older
version of the torque and i forgot to
update it so uh if you are here
specifically for idb which i don't think
uh sorry that will be none
and so uh i mentioned uh
methodically uh dividing the problem and
to do that i use a simple process which
is uh three steps and the first step is
identify uh you can do anything without
data and so the first step is to get
data about your problem so at the
beginning it will be
what are the symptoms
when did the problem start
what have you tried and so on
and it's very important to make sure
that this is a verified data
you have no idea how much hours i've
lost in the past starting an
investigation based on the first
description of the symptoms so don't
trust anybody and don't hesitate to
double check
everything when you have the data you
still need to do something with it so
you need to put it into context and make
a theory about what is happening in your
application
to me this is the hardest step because
this is a creative step
you won't find any step-by-step
description about how to come up with a
theory about a difficult problem that's
something you have to figure out on your
own and experience is going to help you
a lot and also it's nice to have a few
co-workers around to bounce ideas back
and forth
and last but not least
when you have your theory you still need
to verify it
and
more often than not you will find that
your theory is incorrect and this is
this is fine this is part of the process
because uh by discovering that this is
incorrect and by understanding why you
will uncover more data that allows you
to repeat the process and every time you
will be able to make a more refined
theory until you finally manage to crack
the case
so to illustrate this i will tell you
about a bug i investigated as part of my
job so first i'm going to give a bit of
context i'm working at datadog on the
dotnet tracer what is it it's a
component that your install on your
server and then without any modification
of the source code we're going to
instrument your application and we're
going to detect whenever you have an
incoming or outgoing operation such as
an http request or a sql queries and we
will send that information to our
backend and then you can have a nice ui
where you see a summary of everything
that happened in your application
and the way we do that is by rewriting
il at runtime so whenever you load a
supported third party library
we detect that and we rewrite it to
inject our instrumentation code
to do so we use a dotnet profiling api
and it turns out that today you can't
use manage code for the profiling api
you absolutely have to use a native code
usually cpr express and that's why
lately i've been dealing with this kind
of bug that comes from the interaction
between manage and native code
so for the program itself what were the
symptoms so we have a special
test environment where we have two
servers running the open source cms or
chart and they are receiving automated
traffic and the idea is that
one is a baseline server so it's running
the application as is and on the other
one we run with the datadog
instrumentation and then we monitor both
servers to find any difference in
behavior that could be caused by our
instrumentation
and at some point we noticed that the
instrumented server was crashing to
write
about once per day
with an access violation
and so an access violation is not
something that you're supposed to get
from the manage code so i immediately
suspected the native part of our
component
and so the first thing i did is uh
checking the source code for any change
that could explain this
and uh i found nothing in that time
frame nothing impactful
so the next step was to configure the
server to capture a memory dom the next
time it crashed
you can do that by setting a registry
key everything is properly documented on
msdn so i won't spend time on it
it's good to know that i didn't even try
to reproduce the issue locally and the
reason is that since it was happening
only once per day i figured out that my
chances of reproducing locally were
really very slim so i didn't even try
and so the day after i had a memory dump
waiting for me and so i uh opened it in
uh windy bg
so i have it right there and so uh when
i open it the first thing we see that
it's indeed an access violation with
some kind of error code
we see that it happens in the clr in
object native is lockhead so at this
point i don't know what it's doing and
we see that it's trying to read the
memory at the address to be and so as
you may already know the lower addresses
in the process are marked as invalid on
purpose
to catch command programming errors such
as new pointers
and so just as a sanity check
i try to understand where this 2b comes
from so we are reading the value from
the rcx register with the 2c offset
and if i read the value of rcx it's all
fs which is a hexadecimal representation
of minus one so minus one plus two c
equal to b
and so from this point on uh the goal of
the investigation will be to understand
how the value minus one ended up in that
register at that point in time
so the first thing i wanted to know was
exactly what code was running on the
server the moment of the crash
so i loaded the sos extension
and then i run a cls stack which is
going to dump the managed car stack and
here we have an issue because we have
some technical frames but we have
no no method in there so we were
supposed to see the name of the net the
management that are running but we don't
see anything
so it could mean some kind of corruption
on the stack maybe or uh maybe the
application crashed at a at a state that
is not supported by
the sos extension i don't know
but in any case we will have to do
something else
so when that when that happens you can
try using k which is going to dump the
native car stack instead of the manager
stack
and so at the very top we see the object
native is local but here we see a bunch
of functions that are not resolved so
all of them are the managed functions
and the issue is that
when you compile a net application
the final address of the function is not
known yet because it will be decided at
runtime by the jit compiler and so it
cannot be written inside of the pdb
symbols and windpg is a native native
debugger and so it's not capable of
resolving the function if it's not in
the symbols
so to do that you need a debugger with a
special knowledge of the dotnet runtime
and that's what the sos extension is
bringing to windybg
and so i can take the function the
address of this function
and use the ip2md command that is
provided by sos
which stands for instruction pointer to
metadescriptor and is going to resolve
the address for me
and so it's telling me that
this this address is the output cache
filter.dispersed function
inside of our chart
so then
i decided to look at this function to
understand what it's doing fortunately
orchard is open source so i was able to
find it online
and so i have a stripped-down version
here it's a fairly straightforward
implementation of the dispose pattern
but the interesting parts are right
there we are calling monitor that is
entered and the name reminds me a lot of
object native is lockhead so maybe the
two are linked
and also
underscore cache key is an intern string
locking isn't on an internal string
sorry
it's a bad practice but it's not
necessarily wrong still it's a good
thing to note
so then i decided to check the source
code of monitor that is entered so
whenever you want to check the source
code of the net bcl you can go on
sourceof.net or use the compiler
and so there it is uh it's not actually
doing much it's just checking if the
parameter is null and then it's calling
is alternative and then is alternative
is bound to a native function in the clr
so unfortunately we can't dig any
further without the source code of the
clr
and the problem is that
microsoft never published the source
code of the net framework clr
they published the dotted codes dotted
core source code but never.net framework
fortunately there is a trick
and the trick is to know that the core
clr repository on github was created
around the same time frame as dot at 4.6
and back then the source code of.net
core was pretty much mirroring the
source code of the debt framework so if
you go to github and check out the very
first commit from this repository you
will have a pretty good approximation of
the source code of that framework and
it may be enough for your investigations
and so
i looked into it and i searched for
ezenter native and i found this macro
that is binding his alternative to
object native is lockheld so now we have
the confirmation that monitor that is
entered is actually calling object
native is local
so then i try to check what this
function is actually doing
and so here it gets a bit
scary especially if you are not used to
read the source code of the clr because
there are a lot of macros
plus it's c plus plus and c plus plus is
always caring
but basically it's taking one parameter
which is the object that we use for
locking
and then it's calling get thread owning
monitor lock the name is safer
expiratory it's fetching the thread that
is currently owning the lock
and then it's comparing the id of that
thread with the id of the current thread
and it's written returning true or false
depending on the result
so that's pretty much what you would
expect from monitor that is entered so
no surprise there
so then i started to think about what
could go wrong in there why would that
crash and
the most plausible theory i found is
that there is something wrong with the
object that we are giving as a parameter
for the method
so i went back to the memory dump and
checked if i could get this parameter
somehow
and so normally when i need to get the
parameter of a function i will use a cls
stack with the dash p parameter
stack dash p which is going to dump the
manager stack with all the parameters of
the method but as we've seen earlier
sierra stack is not working
so instead i tried dso for dump stack
objects which is going to
browse the managed stack and dump
everything that looks like a pointer to
the managed hip and i was hoping to find
a trace of my parameter in there
but unfortunately i couldn't find it
there is a string there but that's not
the right one
so
it will
it was looking bad so then i decided to
um
well think a bit
outside of the box so basically when you
are calling a method uh the arguments
are going to be stored uh in registers
and so if that register hasn't been
touched by the time the application
crashed i should be able to find the
value of my argument in there
so to verify that i needed to know what
register is being used and so i needed
to know what calling convention the cli
is using
so uh on windows xc4 uh the cri is using
this calling convention the first
argument is stored in the rcx register
the second one on the rdx then r8 and
then r9 and so if between the beginning
of the method and the moment of the
crash the value of the rcx register
hasn't changed i will be able to find my
argument in there
so i decided to check the disassembly of
the method
going to zoom a bit and so basically i
needed to find if between the beginning
of the method and between the lines that
crash the one in yellow
the value of rcx has changed and
unfortunately just right there we are
overwriting rcx with the value from the
memory so
the original value is lost
just in case i looked around for n equal
to the push instruction that will
store the value of the register on the
stack
but i couldn't find any so unfortunately
the value is lost
so i felt like i reached a dead end so i
took one step back and i decided to
think about everything i found at this
point
so we know that is lockheed is causing
the crash
uh we know that is lockheed takes only
one parameter which is the object that
we use for locking
and then i try thinking about what could
go wrong and i thought of two theories
the first one is that something is wrong
with the with the parameter of the
method which is what i've tried to
verify but couldn't
and the other theory that guest trade
owning monitor rock is failing somehow
because that's the only part in the
function where we are actually doing
something significant
but this is a very coarse theory and so
uh before moving forward i needed to
refine it somehow
and so i decided to take a short pause
in my investigation and check books and
articles online about how monitors work
in.net because i needed to understand
exactly how everything worked so that i
could come up with a better theory
and so here is a summary of what what i
found
so let's take this simple object with a
single property and when you're going to
allocate it the layout in memory will
look like this you have the header then
a pointer to the method table and then
the actual value of the field
a little bit of trivia when you have a
reference to the object the reference
points to the method table pointer and
not to the header or the value like you
could think
let's focus on the header
the header is 32 bits wide always even
in a 64-bit process
and it has two parts the first part is
26 bits and it's some kind of
all-purpose storage that can contain
either a hash code or the information
about the thread holding the lock in the
case of a thin lock or the index of a
stick block i will come back to that
the second part of the header is six
bits and is some bit flag that indicates
additional information about your object
for instance there is a flag that
indicates whether the finalizer has run
some private information used by the gc
and also two two bits that indicate what
is stored in the first part of the
header
so
why do we store information on the
header let's look at practical examples
so i have this code i initialize an
object so it's going to allocate the
header in memory and then i call get
hashcode on it so
assuming you didn't override the
implementation of gethashcode it's
expected to return a value that is
unique to your object and that doesn't
change over time
at first i thought that the runtime
would be using
the memory address of the object because
it seems like a clever way of uniquely
identifying an object
but there are two problems with that uh
the first one is that the address of an
object can change over time because
during garbage collection it's going to
move objects around
and the other problem is that the
garbage collector is really trying very
hard to keep all the objects compacted
to compact it together and we expect the
hash to use the whole space available so
the address is not actually
a good way of generating a hash
so instead the runtime is generating a
random number
but
it needs to return the same number the
next time you call get hash code so it
needs to store it somewhere and that
somewhere is the object header
note that since we only have 26 bits of
storage in the header it means that the
hash code of an object actually have
only 26 bits of entropy i know 32 bits
like you could think
okay so that's one use case another one
is what we call a thin lock so just like
before i create an object and i call
lock on it because on.net you can lock
on any reference type
the way it works is that the runtime is
going to use an atomic interrupt
operation to store thread information
inside of the header of the object and
then it will execute the critical
section and when it leaves it's going to
clear that information
when you think about it that's one of
the fastest possible ways of
implementing a lock because the header
is next to your object so you are almost
guaranteed that it will be available in
the cache of your cpu so it's going to
be very fast
but it's not always that easy and so for
instance let's consider what is going to
happen if you have two threads competing
for the same lock
so thread one arrives first it acquires
the lock so the runtime is going to
store the information in the header that
thread one is owning the lock and it
executes the critical section
and then stretch your eyes and try to do
the same thing it can't store you can't
acquire the log because a thread one
already already owns it and so now uh
what is going to happen thread two needs
to go to sleep and it needs to be woken
up when uh the lock is freed so we need
to store somewhere the information that
thread two is waiting to acquire the
lock so we need a waitlist basically
and where are we going to store that
since the header is already full
another problematic case is
when we combine both scenarios so we
create an object we call get hashcode
the runtime generates a random number
and stores it in the header and then we
try to lock
the instance so the runtime tries to
store the thread information in the
header but we can't because it's already
full so where are we going to store that
in older scenarios
whenever we need to store information in
the header but it's already full the
runtime is going to use what we call the
sync table
so it's a table allocated somewhere in
memory
and the runtime is going to look for the
next free entry in the table and it's
going to replace whatever information is
in the header with the index of that
entry
and then every entry is actually two
pointers we have one back pointer to the
object and then one pointer to another
chunk of memory that we call a thing
block and the thing block is big enough
to store everything we need so the
information about the lock the hash code
and maybe even other stuff i don't know
so
so basically in short the runtime is
going to store information on the object
header as much as possible because it's
fast but when it counts it will instead
use the thing table
and so i went back to my problem and now
i had enough information to refine my
theories and so now i had three theories
about what is going wrong so still the
address of the parameter could be wrong
or the sync table could be corrupted
somehow
or the index of the thing of the thing
table that we store inside of the object
header could be corrupted somehow
so in both cases we have some kind of
problem with the thing table but in one
case it's a table itself and in the
other case it's an index that we store
in the object
so can we try to verify the theories
so i went back to my memory dump and
since we are interested in the sync
table i tried using the syncblk command
which is going to browse the thing table
and dump anything block that is
currently used by a lock
and when i execute it we see something
interesting it finds a one thing block
and uh when when it tries to read the
thread info it fails with some kind of
error so it's very interesting because
we are suspecting that something is
wrong with the thing table and when we
try to read it we have an error
so then i try to use a sing blk-all
which is going to read
the thing table but this time dump all
the thing blocks and not only the ones
that are used by a lock
and we see that it stops at index 226
which is the thing block with the error
with the error
so at this point i'm not capable of
concluding whether it means that
zero happens on the last thing block of
the table or maybe synblk stops at the
first error or maybe the thing table is
so corrupted that it cannot be read past
this point
but in any case it seems that i have
some kind of memory corruption
and i decided to stop my investigation
there and wait for another memory dump
so why is that it's because i have some
signs that could point towards a memory
corruption and this kind of corruption
could be completely random for instance
imagine that you are writing to a wrong
pointer you will be overwriting a random
part of the memory and this time it
happened to be the thing table but maybe
in the next crash it will be something
completely different
so i didn't want to spend too much time
on the sink table before knowing for
sure that this was the source of the
problem
fortunately by the time i reached this
point in the investigation i already had
another memory dump waiting for me
and so i have it right there
and so just like before we see an access
violation
uh we see it happens in object native is
lockhead and we see that we are reading
the memory at address 2b so it looks
really similar to the previous one
so i try loading sos
and then run clr stack to know what is
running
just like before cll stack is not
working
so i tried using
k
and then take the top frame and reserve
it with ip2md
just like before it's happening in our
chart in output crash filter.dispose so
it looks really good because it seems
that
every crash has the same symptoms which
is going to make the investigation much
easier
and so then i try uni uh running thing
blk
and this time we don't have an error
which is nice
and
we still see something significant that
the second block
has no thread info
so it means that the lock is orphaned so
basically at some point one thread
acquired the lock and it died without
freeing it which is a sign of a
programming error so
i checked the source code of our chart
to understand how we could end up with
orphan locks
and so what i found is
so basically orchard is an asp.net mvc
application and it's using two events as
part of its locking mechanism
in controller that on action executing
is going to acquire the lock
and then in another event
action filter that end result executed
is going to call
push cache filter.disperse which is
going to release the lock
and the thing is for this to work you
need both events to be raised on the
same thread because only the thread that
has acquired a lock can freeze
but asp.net makes absolutely no
guarantee about that and it's entirely
possible that the two events are raised
on separate threads which is how you end
up with orphan logs
so this is not great that's not
something you want to happen in your
application
but it still doesn't explain why we have
an access violation and since this could
have been caused by our instrumentation
i absolutely needed to get to the bottom
of it
and so
i was a bit out of leads and so i
figured out that it was time to focus uh
on the disassembly so yeah we we have a
bug in this version of windy bg where
the disassembly window
is empty until you run one command
and so basically i needed to understand
what were we doing exactly in the
function uh at the moment of the crash
and i don't know about you but
personally uh when i see that i don't
understand much
i mean i know what most of the
instructions are doing individually and
i'm saying most not all of them
but i'm completely unable to reconstruct
mentally the flow of the program like i
would do with some c sharp code
but fortunately we already have the c
press press code as a function and so
it's just going to be a matter of
mapping the c plus plus to the native
instructions
and the way i do that is by looking for
instructions that are easy to recognize
so for instance this one
here we are reading the memory at some
address and thanks to the symbols it was
reserved to a g underscore piecing table
in the clr and so then if i check the
source code and i find one place where
we read this table i know that this line
of code was compiled to this instruction
so i check the source code
and we are not using g underscore
piecing table anywhere so that usually
means that one of the function that you
are calling got in line during
compilation
so you also need to check the function
that you are calling so i checked uh get
thread owning monitor lock
and so this one is much bigger so i'm
not going to try and understand what
he's doing for now
all i'm interesting in is uh is it using
g underscore piecing table somewhere
and it turns out it is and also i got
lucky because it only use it at one
place and so i have the guarantee that
this line of code is mapped to
the native instruction that we saw
so then i kept looking for a stuff that
you can recognize
and here we have two if blocks and each
of them is checking if some bit flags
are set
and if we go back to the native
instructions we have two chords to the
bt instruction and bt stands for bit
test we check if some bits are set so
there is a good probability that those
two bt instructions
are coding for those two if blocks
so to verify that i check the value of
the constants that we are testing and so
for instance a bit sync block is
hashcode has this value
which is this binary representation
which means check if the 27th bit is set
and one a in hexadecimal is 26
which means that
this instruction is checking this
constant
so here you may be confused because
we are talking about the 27th bit and we
are calling bt with the value 26 and the
trick is that bt is 0 base so bt0 is
testing the first bit bt1 is testing the
second bit and bt26 is testing the 27th
bit
so then i did the same thing for the
other constant just to be sure so
bitsync block is hash or sync block
index
this is a binary representation and it
means check if the 28th bit is set and
so 1b hexadecimal is 27 and so this is
this native instruction
and so every time i was able to map a
line of c plus plus to the native
instruction i annotate in my code so
that i will little by little reconstruct
my mental image as a function
and so i kept looking for interesting
stuff and here we have test rcx rcx
whenever you are testing a register
against itself you can be almost sure
that it's either a null check or a false
boolean check
so i check the source code and here we
have another check so there is a chance
that
it was compiled into this instruction
so assuming this is the case it will
mean that the rcx register is storing
the address of pthread so let's see
where it's coming from is coming from
the memory at address rdx press 8 rdx
comes from rax plus rcx times 8
and rax contains the address of the
thing table
so given that rax contains the address
of the servicing table
rax plus rcx times 8 sounds a lot like
if we are reading the sync table at a
given index with the index stored in the
rcx register which would mean that this
instruction codes for this
this line of code
assuming this is the case it will mean
that the result which is a pointer to
the thing block will be stored in the
rdx register
and so then when we read rdx press 8 it
will mean that we are doing a curling
gate monitor on the sync block and
fetching the amanda score holding thread
field
so here it's a bit of a stretch and so i
really needed to verify this before
moving forward and so basically what i
needed to verify is
is reading the memory at address rdx
press 8 when rdx stores the address of
the sync block the same thing as calling
get monitor on the sync block and
fetching the m underscore holding thread
field
in other words
uh
i assumed that i had the sync block in
the rdx register and so i tried to
figure out what was that rdx 8
so
to do that i checked further source code
of the get monitor function all he's
doing is returning the address of the m
underscore monitor field and then i
checked
the sync block class
and m underscore monitor is the first
field of the class
in memory uh the fields are going to be
stored in the same order as they are
declared in the code
except summers some exceptions
so that will mean that m underscore
monitor is going to be stored at the
beginning of the object and so it's
going to be stored at offset 0. so at
offset 0 we have
the aware lock that is stored in the m
underscore monitor field so then i check
the structure of the overlock
and it has three fields the first one is
another score monitor held so it's the
first field so it's going to be stored
at the beginning of the object at a set
zero and it's so long it's four bytes so
it's going to end at zero x4
then we have m underscore recursion is
going to be stored next to the previous
field so out of set 0x4 and it's an
enzyme long it's going to be 4 bytes so
it's going to end out of set 0x8 and
then we have amanda score holding thread
which is the field we are looking for
which is going to be stored next to the
previous one and so it's going to be
stored at offset 0x8 and so we have the
confirmation that this native
instruction is a sensing as calling get
monitor on the thing block and fetching
the amazon holding straight field
so i annotated the native instructions
with my findings and at this point i
felt like i had enough information to
focus on the crash itself
so here we are calling test rcx rcx
which is if-b thread is null
and so the way it's going to work is
that it's going to set the zero flag of
the cpu if the value of rcx is zero
so basically it's going to set the zero
flag if this thread is null
then we have this
this ge instruction
ge is going to jump to the target
address if the zero flag of the cpu is
set so it's going to jump if rcx was
zero so it's going to jump if p thread
was null
then we have the line that caused the
crash
and uh if we got there it means that we
didn't jump at the previous instruction
so it means that rcx wasn't zero and so
p thread wasn't null and so we were
there
that will mean that we crashed when
colleen gets thread id on pthread
and so a gets right id tries to fetch
the id of the thread
and so to move forward we have to verify
if the thread id is stored at offset 2c
because we are crashing when reading the
offset 2c from pthread
so i'm going to do the same verification
as before but without the fancy drawings
we're just going to count how much
memory is used by all the fields before
the thread id and see if it sums up to
2c
so
an underscore state is a straight state
it's 4 bytes
we have an unsigned long it's 4 bytes we
have 3 pointers it's a 64-bit process so
it's 8 bytes each
then we have a g word the word is always
4 bytes and then finally we have our
field if we do the sum that means there
is 36 bytes before the field
and 2c is 44 in decimal so it doesn't
add up so does it mean that my theory
was wrong
well not quite because if you pay close
attention you will see that thread
inherits from i unknown and if you check
the source code you will see that inon
has some abstract functions which means
that thread will have some virtual
functions
and in c plus plus when an object has
virtual function is going to expose a v
table
and
the compiler is going to generate
kind of like an additional field at the
beginning of the object that is going to
store a pointer to the v table
and since it's a 64-bit process that
pointer is going to be 8 bytes so if we
redo the math we have 44 and so we have
the confirmation that the thread id is
at offset to c and so we have the
confirmation that we crash when reading
the thread id
so that will mean that
the crash occurred at this function
which will mean that p thread would be
-1 because if you remember what i
checked at the very beginning we are
reading memory at rs2b which is a 2c
plus minus 1.
so now the question is where does p
threat comes from and why is it minus
one
so this time is
we need to focus on guess thread owning
monitor lock and actually understand
what it's doing
so
we start by calling get bits get bits is
going to read the header of the object
that we use as a parameter for the
locking
then it's going to check
if
the is hash or sync block index bit is
set so if you remember my explanation
the header has two parts one all-purpose
storage and then a few bit flags that
indicate among other things what is
stored in the first part and so here we
check if the first part is storing a
hash or the index surfacing block
we know that is the case because if that
wasn't then we would have executed the
else part of the if and so we wouldn't
have gotten to the crashing instruction
and so then we check the flag that
indicate whether it's a hash card
we know that's not the case otherwise we
wouldn't have gotten to the crash and
crashing instruction
and so at this point we know that the
header is storing the index of a sting
block so if you remember my explanation
it means that the runtime tries to store
something in the header but it was full
and so it moved everything to a sync
block and instead store the index in the
header
so then we apply a bit mask to retrieve
that index and then we read the thing
table and we fetch we really sorry
we read the same table at that index and
we fetch the pointer to the thing block
so if you remember my description of the
thing table
we have the index so we get the entry at
that index and that in then in that
entry we have a pointer to the thing
block and we are fetching that pointer
um and then we
now that we have the pointer to the
thing block we get the part of the thing
blocks that contain the lock information
and more specifically we get the address
of the thread owning the lock
and then p thread is not null because
it's minus one and so we get to the
crashing line
and so that will mean that we are
crashing because uh we have the value
minus one stored in the m underscore
holdings thread feed
uh
which begs the question why would we end
up with the value minus one
but first uh before moving uh too far
let's try to verify it
so to verify it we will need the address
of the sting block
and uh if we go back to our annotated
native code we found out that at this
point we have
the address of the sync block in the rdx
register
and
the rdx register is not touched
past this point we never change the
value so it should still be intact in
the memory lamp
so if i get back to my memory dump i'm
not going to need that anymore
and i read the value of the rdx register
i should have the address of the thing
block and in fact if i copy this value
and look for it inside of my wind dbg
window
i find the output of my sync blk command
in the second column which contains the
address of the sync block so we have the
confirmation that this is indeed a thing
block and interestingly it's the orphan
sync blocks
so then i can use uh yeah i need to copy
it sorry
there we go then i can use a dd command
for dumb d words to read the memory at
this address and it's going to display
it by chunks of four bytes
and then i can try to map those values
to the values of the thing block
so basically i know that uh the
structure of the
of this part of the thing block looks
like that
i have those values in my memory and i'm
just going to map them
so m underscore monitor held is the
first four bytes so it's going to be one
m underscore recursion is the next four
byte so it's going to be one
and if you go back to the output of sing
blk you see that you have monitor head
and recursion columns and both of them
are one so it seems like we are on the
on the right track
and then m underscore holding thread is
the next eight bytes so it's all f and
so it's minus one so we have the
definite confirmation that the thing
block is storing the value minus one
which is causing the crash so we still
need to figure out how this value ended
up in the sync block
so fortunately -1 it is a very
significant value easy to recognize and
so i was able to uh scan the source code
of the clr until finding all the places
where we are storing minus one in the
same block and there is only one
so it's happening in the object header
get sync block function
which is called during the promotion for
a syn lock to a thing block so basically
this is called whenever the runtime
tries to store something in the header
the header is full and so it tries to
move that to a thing block this happens
in getting block
and so
we have the part where we store minus
one in piece thread
and
above we have a very interesting command
saying that the lock is orphan which is
consistent with what we found so far
then if we check where it's coming from
we get there if p thread is null and a p
thread come from this
pc lot thread id dispenser id to thread
with validation so that's a mouthful
and so uh let's check what it's doing
so more c plus plus yay
uh i'm not going to explain this one but
what you need to know is basically the
function is taking an id
and it's returning a pointer to a thread
and internally it's using some kind of
table to get that pointer
so why would the runtime need something
like that
well let's go back to my explanation
about thin locks
i told you that the runtime is going to
store some information about the thread
inside of the object header but i never
explain what kind of information is
going to store
well ideally
the runtime will need the address of the
thread because it needs the address to
fetch the thread instance
unfortunately the address of this thread
is going to be 32 or 64 bits depending
on the bitness of your process
and we only have 26 bits of usable space
in the header so it's just not going to
fit
instead the runtime is going to store
the id of the thread so here you may be
thinking how is that helping because we
are still trying to solve 32 bits
instead of 26
and the trick is that the runtime we try
to aggressively reuse the thread ids to
keep the maximum under 26 bits so what i
mean is as soon as the thread is going
to die the next thread that spawns is
going to reuse the same id
and so to get above that limit
you need to spawn more than 67 million
thread
and given that every thread has a one
megabyte of stack uh you're probably
going to run out of memory way before
getting even near this limit
um
but the runtime still needs the at the
address of the thread not the id and so
it's also keeping a table that allows it
to associate this id to the address of
the of the of the thread and this table
is a syn lock strategy dispenser that
we've just seen
all right so
what do we know
we know that the access violation is
caused by the value -1 stored as a
thread address in the thing block
we know that this happens when a syn
lock is promoted to a sync block but the
thread id is missing from the table
so in this case the runtime is going to
store -1 instead of the address
which begs the question in what
condition can the thread id be missing
from the table
we also know that thread ids are
aggressively reused to keep the maximum
and
the maximum id under 26 bits and the way
it works is that
when a thread is die
when the thread is dead and the final
finalizer is going to run is going to
clear the thread id from the table so
that it can be reused by the next uh the
next thread and that's how it can be
missing from the table
and so that will mean that
the craft would happen
well the value would be missing from the
table if
the threat died
by the point where we tried to fetch its
id
so i feel like at this point i had
a complete enough
understanding of the problem to try and
write a repro
so
i switched to visual studio and i wrote
this code
so basically what i'm doing is i'm
creating a bunch of objects nothing
special about them it's just new object
and then for each of those objects i'm
creating a new thread a new thread will
try to acquire the lock
so at this point the object header is
empty so the runtime is going to store
the id in the object header and also is
going to feed the table that actuates
the id to the address of
the thread
then i let all those threads die and so
i will end up with orphan locks
and then i force a garbage collection to
be sure that the finalizer of the thread
is going to run and when it's going to
run it's going to clear those ids from
the table
then i enumerate again on my objects and
this time i call get hashcode so runtime
is going to generate a random number
it's going to try to store that number
in the header but the header is full so
it's going to get a thing block in the
same table
store the index of the thing block in in
the object header
and move the information inside of the
sync block and when doing so it's going
to reserve the id of the thread and try
to get the thread address so that it can
store it in the sync block
but when doing so it won't be able to
find it because it got it got cleared
here and so instead it's going to store
minus one
and so here we have all the conditions
for the crash so i just enumerate on my
object and like a monitor that is
entered which is going to call is
lockhead which will uh cause a crashing
instruction because we check if p thread
is null but we don't check if this
thread is equal to minus one
so if i run this
you will see that it crashes with a
fatal execution engineer so i don't see
the access violation in there because
i'm running with the debugger and
changing the error handling a bit but
it's exactly the same crash and as a
matter of fact i have the same error
code
so
we've identified the problem that there
are still
a few uh
unresolved questions and the first one
is why is the baseline server not
crashing because if you remember my test
environment i have two servers running
orchard and
only only the instrumented server is
crashing even though we just figured out
that it's a bug in the dot at runtime
and the trick is that our child use a
finite set of lock as part of its cache
mechanism
so what i mean is the lock are used for
caching the output when you
try to load a page and since we use
automatic traffic we always load the
same page and so it's always the same
lock that is going to be used
and the crash only happens if a north
end thin lock is promoted after the
balance thread was collected this is a
very precise set of conditions
and it's especially unlikely to happen
in asp.net application because it's
going to use a thread pull so the thread
is unlikely to die
and the thing is uh if
all the locks got promoted without those
conditions being filled then the crash
cannot occur anymore so basically when
you start the application uh
it's going to use syn locks then they
are getting going to get promoted so
here you have a window of opportunity
for the crash and then if it didn't
crash you can let your application run
for days and it's not going to crash
anymore
and the thing is
the thing is the instrumented server is
redeployed every time we do a charge in
our codebase which is multiple times per
day whereas the baseline server is never
restarted because we never need to
restart it and that's the only reason
why the crash was only occurring on the
instrumented server
there's another
question what has started the incident
this is a bug that has been in the dot
net runtime for uh
as long as i could find
uh and in fact it's still in the dot at
runtime today
so what did it start crashing someday
well this time it's our fault
i'm saying that we run our chart but we
are not exactly running it basically we
modify it to add some workload
just to better test our instrumentation
and since this is uh asynchronous
workload we
changed to use an asynchronous
controller because by default our child
uses synchronous controller
and if you remember
we end up with often luck
which is one of the conditions for the
crash if those two events are raised on
separate threads
and it's an implementation detail but
when you use a synchronous mvc
controller those two events are always
going to be raised on the same thread uh
simply because since there is no
asynchronous operation then asp.net has
no reason to switch the thread and
that's that's the reason why this bug
has never been fought instead of orchard
and it's us by switching to an
asynchronous controller that created the
condition for the crash
all right so to wrap it up
the more complex investigation the more
important it is to verify every theory
or assumption so uh if you've seen the
the way i proceeded i try to break down
the big problem into a smaller problem
and then every time i spend
all the necessary time to verify the
assumption i was making and by doing so
you make sure that
you are
little by little making progress because
uh if you try to uh
resonate about the whole thing uh by
basing yourself on a fake assumption
first assumption sorry
uh then you're going to get lost
eventually because your reasoning is not
going to work and you're not you will
not be able to understand
where you did something wrong so it's
very important to verify everything at
every step on the way
also take the time to refresh your
knowledge on the affected area that will
be that will allow you to make better
theories about what is happening so in
this case uh when i uh
started suspecting that it has something
to do with a monitor
uh i took a break i checked books i
checked articles online until i had a
clear grasp of how monitors work in
dotnet and it really helped me to make
better theories about what is happening
and the last piece of advice is don't
give up
raymond chen which is the author of the
all-new thing blog says that uh
debugging is an exercise in optimism and
as i agree 100
with that you're going to be wrong a lot
of times and uh it's part of the process
so it's okay and every time you are
wrong you are going to learn something
new about your problem and uh if you
don't give up eventually you should be
able to get to the bottom of it
if you like it there are more
investigations on my blog so uh make
sure to check it
and uh feel free to ping me on twitter
if you want
so uh that's it and uh i think we we
still have plenty of time if you if you
have questions about this
well no question about after showing
that much assembly girl i don't know if
that's a good sign
yes
ah sorry can you can you speak louder
because i can't hear you
uh well this is really good uh
so you use exactly the same kind of tour
uh
of course a release code is going to be
harder to read but most of the times
your crash dump is about to be released
because well usually when you use a
crash jump it means that the crash is
occurring in production
otherwise you would just directly attach
the debugger
and so uh yeah most of the time it's
going to be released on and it's fine if
you have symbols it's going to help you
a lot
if you don't have symbols good luck but
the information is still there somewhere
i think there was another question
yes
or it is going to be tricky i'm not
hearing anything
oh so the question is how long i spent
on this uh i think about three days
uh yeah that was three days
investigation
i don't know uh probably when i stopped
getting lazy and fix it
uh i already opened the pr on github
where i explained everything about the
problem
i
just need somebody to pick up pick it up
we have two problems with this with this
uh the first problem is that it's uh
it's very hard to understand why the
runtime is doing that uh there is i mean
i think it's at least as hard as net
four and it's probably even harder than
that
uh
it's hard to know why at some point
somebody decided to store minus one
rather than null
for the for the thread
and we see the command the lock has been
orphaned so it was a conscious decision
and the other thing is that this bug is
incredibly unlikely to happen because
well imagine that is going to happen to
you you're going to think about what is
wrong in my application you will see
that you have our fan locks so you're
going to fix that because nobody live
off unlocks in their application and
then the program is gone so you're not
going to think about it anymore
so uh so yeah it's very likely to say
that stay there for a while
so yeah
in your example you create when you
reproduce
okay uh so the reason i so the question
is why in my repro i created 16 objects
instead of just one uh and that's
because uh well i did not explain the
details about uh the
going back back back back about the id
uh to thread with validation uh but
basically i took some shortcuts in my
explanation and uh the crash is only
going to happen if uh we made that um
so basically uh he's going
he's going to use a table
uh that table has some uh i don't
remember what it's called but basically
it's a linked list and it's going to
store a links
it's going to store a free list to know
how to reuse the node
and there is an implementation details
that make that
you're going to have this problem only
if
you meet this
if id uh so there is this if id
infer or equal of is heidi and you're
going to have null only if it's bigger
and uh basically because there is some
precise condition inside of it by
creating 16 objects i make sure that
it's going to happen
because if i have only one object it's
actually going to reuse an old
so that's actually interesting because
there is another bug in there that i i
didn't try to explore
but basically if the id is lower it's
going to fetch an old node uh
of the linked list instead of returning
null which means that it's going to
return the address of a different thread
and so it means that
for your orphan lock it may actually get
the address of a different thread and
i'm not sure what the consequence would
be
but in that case it won't
crash so i think that's it so uh thank
you everybody and
any case i will be around if you want to
to discuss
you